hello and welcome to the book club this
is a series of videos where we read a
book together and then talk about it
both here on the channel and in our
Goodreads there's a link in the
description to that I'm joined this time
by my husband Dan hello who is a
classics and English student so he
actually is used to talking about books
and this time around we're talking about
the metamorphosis by Franz Kafka what's
it about well a bit of an absurdist
piece this time quite different than one
that you've done last last episode I
think but basically our main character
Gregor Samsa awakes one morning to find
himself transformed into a monstrous
cockroach and a series of events in tale
and basically his life kind of crumbles
around around and really earnest and the
other thing to point out as it is a
short story it's not all know what it's
like a hundred and twenty old pages
general about yeah and it's very
different from what we've read before so
for one thing this is fiction and it is
a very bizarre piece of fiction you read
this as Populi be I did yes so in my
first years I've been year 11 it was one
of our set texts in fact I led this is
my copy and I'll answer I mean it's got
her Danny Danny its III my class and I
think some notes throughout the book
which is quite fine it was kind of
useful to me to see which pitted
underline key points so I suppose we can
start by saying 1913 yes as well it's
early in his career
yeah and so I guess why don't we how did
you how different if you find this from
reading of a nonfiction especially in
this shorter as well yeah I only read it
in like three set sittings I think
whereas something like sapiens it was a
long process and one of the things about
it is it does feel very stream of
consciousness I know it wasn't written
in one might unlike at least one of
those other stories but it kind of has
that feeling that he was just writing
whatever came into his head and I feel
like that suited the way that I read it
yeah and I mean just reading fiction
because this is different from a lot of
fiction I've read before because it's
absurdist and it is quite the I actually
picture was going on quite grossly it
definitely made me feel things a
surprisingly it may be very sympathetic
towards a giant cockroach yeah I
emphasized with the character of Gregor
an awful lot yeah am i weird for that I
don't think so no
that's kind of the point I mean it's
worth mentioning that while it's an
absurdist piece from the the phrase
Casca esque it's showing I'm around
quite a bit and that kind of it's part
and parcel of defining absurdist writing
except the slight difference I suppose
you could make with Kafka is that this
is usually in kind of an insect II ver
meanie undertone that first phrase
actually I'm transformed into a
monstrous cockroach is an interesting
one because the text itself was
originally written in German so it's
really interesting not only for to look
at the book from a plot and kind of
story perspectives but also consider
some of the kind of socio-cultural
considerations which you don't always
get to do with fiction but you do get to
with translated text so for instance the
original German words they use directly
translates as vermin now you can kind of
see the link there between them saying
right cockroach interestingly though the
German sense of the word vermin actually
means something more like rats yeah I
better get ever really specified I mean
it goes into details about like hidden
numerous legs and he emits certain
substances he's injured there's like a
scabs that is like an evil kind of thing
there is a kind of s and there are
illusions that he's almost got kind of a
um carapace body yeah there are it's
implies that he's insect like an insect
yeah rather than a wrap you know as you
says it's a sort of a cultural thing I
guess but the human vermin probably have
different connotations yeah which for an
isolated instance like that considering
the translated choices that haven't have
to be made it's also interesting to kind
of think about how much the book then
reflects curvature and attitude to not
only kind of life at the time but how
kind of German is the story and how many
of those cultural considerations do you
then have to think about while reading
the text especially approaches to humor
there are moments where the the reason
that you feel slightly alienated which
is a massive scene within the text is
that there are times where there's this
kind of weird quite twisted sense of
humor and
going on along with this really quite
crushingly sad story well he completely
misunderstands people's intentions
towards him yeah I mean the first thing
that he does is he wakes up and thinks
I'm an insect oh I've got to go to work
I'm late to work I've got to go which is
which is obviously you know it tells
something very important about the
character
yeah because I don't think a huge number
of people would wake up and think that
you know you know and I said I'm sure
part of that is the cat what other part
of it is the culture and he was well it
is in Prussia technically we I think so
so you know it's a it's in the Prussian
Empire you know as a young man we do
later and he's basically just providing
for his family
you know there's this real work ethic
that he had to be at work at like 7
o'clock and wouldn't get back into a
very lake the sole breadwinner for the
family hmm yeah and taking off from that
the sense as we talked about earlier
about about that kind of alienation and
him being the sole breadwinner for the
family and upon the first reading the
text you kind of think right what his
life is going downhill because of this
transformation as he was just saying a
minute ago and he wakes up and the first
thing he does is within kind of pages
have been waking up realizing he's been
transformed his box is knocking on his
door asking why he's not at work his
work hasn't been up to scratch and one
of the things that you kind of can take
from a first reading is that how his
mental state affects his kind of
physical world around him and himself so
to say that if he's you know he things
are going poorly for him after this
transformation and that writ of affects
his relationships in the house and
certainly assists is quite an
interesting yeah and the only
environment of his room yeah as he gets
more insect-like a more monstrous he
what he loses his humanity and so the
room becomes dusty and dusty oh yeah we
starts walking on the ceiling and things
like that yeah I think the point about
assist is an interesting one because
thinking about it now there's almost two
parallel lines of development in terms
of not sexuality but I guess some was
like empowerment yeah with his sister on
one hand who goes from being all such a
girly girl I guess
so yeah to being recognized at the very
end of our parents is this strong
independent woman who actually
apparently doesn't need a man and then
at the same time the father who when you
first meet him is sort of in a drowsy
asleep and things like that and very old
and decrepit but I think it's I think
it's when he comes out of the room it's
the end of Part two I want to say when
the father comes back and he's all to
the decked in like this new uniform and
he's glorious it's very striking image
of like him striding back into the house
it's also interesting to look at those
family figures around him as at the very
beginning of the video you said that
you've you had acquired quite an
overwhelming sense of sympathy for him
looking at each character and looking at
them as kind of various levels of
sympathy so the most strikingly
unsympathetic I suppose you could say is
his father yeah
however at no point despite the fact
knowing that as you could read through
the book or the story I should say the
family come to realise that Gregor needs
to go because they're you know he's
dragging them down and they're they're
reaching a more kind of poverty-stricken
state but at no point does the father
ever suggest you know killing him for
one is quite striking so that says it
yeah yeah yeah and for the father who is
the most kind of hurtful I suppose he
never reaches that level each member of
the family
Retin and sympathy to a degree he sort
of stops seeing the humanity
straightaway yeah you know he's shoeing
and like of like vermin back into the
rumors the sister sees him scold his
brother and the mother kind of never
really loses it
no ill always sees him as her son which
is also interesting from a
characterization point how much of a
role does another really play yeah they
think of one thing that sets it apart is
that the sister cut it plays are
certainly a larger role that the mother
is still very much at this kind of old
view figure she isn't particularly
characterised um she's up she's much
more in the background than the striking
father and um the sister with almost
certainly the violin
finger yeah well I mean I'll start to
say that those third the other entry
into that is the lodgers so three
gentlemen who
to arrive at the house and they take in
to make money and I'm sure that it's
obviously not the story that's just
about what it's written about there's a
lot of allegory in this yeah what do you
think they are for why are they on the
story
certainly not taking them at face value
as you say this kind of Prussian
old-world kind of society is being
established as I would certainly say
that you could possibly make a kind of
socio-political reading into those
characters based on the the one kind of
main speaker for the group certainly
that isn't particularly hard to take a
political reading from their kind of
reactions towards Gregor there's like a
society as large Gary I mean do you
think that Kafka identified with Gregor
or like what what did he put those men
into is how he was perceived by the rest
of society because I think him in a
relatively similar position to Gregor in
terms of yeah allegro nautically it's
very very similar also these are the
kind of it's interesting earlier how you
you mentioned the kind of not
necessarily sexual but kind of gender
empowerment perspective Katka of an
individual focus and remembering back to
year 11 I remember he was a very very
tormented individual and both sexually
for one he was he was really quite
bizarre guy um but I would certainly
think that as you say those three
individuals representative of how he
thought society saw him and so it's kind
of self reflective in a way yeah as a
bit which was quite sad yeah I mean to
be said I think part of the reason and
sighs was grabber so much is that the
reaction of woken up and I've been
turned to an insect basically nobody
would ever think I need to go to work
but if you if that happened to me when I
was saying my fourth year at Oxford I'm
without question that would be the first
thing I thought hmm like I think I think
it was indicative it was the same thing
as people miss reading people's
intentions and so to suggest oh we
should get the doctor and him thinking
oh no no one can see me like this
without you know I could definitely
understand
where he was coming from and it's those
it's those moments where where kind of
logic is subverted that really make it
as kind of a cataract yeah yeah and that
absurdist kind of vibe and on a kind of
absurdist note it's worse I think
drawing a comparison if we're looking at
as we were talking about the kind of
socio-cultural aspects Bertold Brecht
ethic theater hmm he one of the kind of
ID identifying features of epic theatre
was this notion of the alienation effect
or the here we go come on you're 11 the
fried ins effect I think it's cause
which is basically this aspect in epic
theater where an audience would be made
wouldn't be made incredibly obvious to
them that they are watching a piece of
theater so things like breaking the
fourth wall also oddly comic moments in
very kind of serious parts in the plot
the moments that we have in here where
you do think that is just so that that
is bizarre that is absurd
we go very well you're reading a book
yeah and and it was those those writings
that then informed rekt he had okay oh
really I profound influence on him and
both of the sheep German because I mean
the other interesting thing by the way I
noticed was being the prose opposed to
describe what the prose is like it's
like a bear room like it is very crisp
um it's kind of unflinching which we've
given a subject matter me this mix makes
it even more horrifying yeah you know
but at the same time so it's drawing you
in and drawing you in and saying you
know look at this without blinking look
at how horrifying this transformation is
but at the same time you're reading a
book yeah well you know that it's that
deferring your way in and making your
you're constantly aware that you are
reading a piece of writing is he's
drawing you in but only not so that you
get so involved that you forget that
this you go wake up this kind of meta
relationship with the book in that you
always know you're reading it it doesn't
suck you in like a I don't know again
returns or something yeah exactly
something whether where the text is so
flower is the wrong word but they're
such template
some kind of description and you know
metaphor similarly all of these devices
to really pull you in and make you feel
part of the world rather than as like an
observer hmm and that whole observer
vibe of that are kind of if you look at
how space is used in the book interiors
and exteriors oh no you never hear about
the outside world it's a very
claustrophobic effect yeah which is how
you know Gregor was early life when he's
reflecting on before he's woken up and
he's realized he's changed you start to
hear that he's not happy with his life
you know he feels unappreciated from his
family he's a sole breadwinner but
they've just taken it for granted he
doesn't like his a kind of door-to-door
salesman a traveling salesman yeah and
that kind of being up and about and
moving everywhere means that he kind of
the relationships he has in his life are
really very meaningful so he's already
unhappy there so you could say that
while the transformation the physical
transformation affect his life his life
has already been affected and
psychologically so you've got this weird
kind of does this mind inform the body
or the body and from the mind does his
transformation cause it unhappiness or
is it that original unhappiness that
causes the transformation sort of
eroding the mind body yeah duality yep
very much like a metamorphosis it's not
just one change it's a series of stages
you are good this is why I bring them on
the channel why should people redo them
I think people should read it because it
is a classic
literary text it's a fine fine example
of absurdist writings and it's just it's
very different to I think anything else
that you will read it's a challenging
route it is yeah it's definitely not
something that you settle in in front of
a fire or like cozy evenings yeah I
think oh I'm just going to crack open
the metamorphic it's not feel good read
I have to go lucky you know but in the
same way that you might watch a film
talk about some soul maybe um you know
Anders list you don't watch it because
your anticipate they'll enjoy it you're
watching it because it's a challenging
piece and there's lots to interpret from
it yeah and it says it's those many
interpretations both literary and kind
of met
literary I what's happening within the
plot and what has informed the writing
of the book like those socio-cultural
factors we spoke about that makes it
really interesting too not only is it
absurdist but if you just purely look at
it from a work in translation and how
they translated it like it's pretty
interesting one so we're only one part
of the book club we want to hear what
you guys thought about the mesomorph
assist if you read it so put them down
in the comments and also comment on what
you thought of I mean it's not really
our it's really your interpretation I'm
here as a passenger really it's a great
it's a great combination of kind of fuse
play because I very much like the small
fictitious works where as you're far
more kind of well-read in in nonfiction
yeah maybe I approach it more from a
structure and prospective I find because
I did a lot of solid did you ever be
much waiting I think my creative idea
okay yeah we're 41st approaching from
the language yeah yeah yeah sorry I also
made English you did I do my strange
rocks yeah a little bit you might have
just been interested in one section of
the world okay yeah but the next but
we're going to be reading I just I
haven't found a copy oh here is as
popular requested on our Goodreads group
a brief history of time by it Stephen
Hawking so this is very much my domain
yeah it's good I tried to read this
another 10 and I remember I got laughed
at in the primary school playground
probably good reason but we're both
going to try and read this yes I think
it's very gonna be about a month because
we've both got a lot on and you've got
enough to read as it is yeah but if
you'd like to take part in the next book
clubs then get yourself coffee either
from local bookshop or from your local
library and try and read along it's not
actually that long it's less than 200
pages has fantastic tire comes like that
and it's a classic of sort of science
communication so I highly encourage you
to get a copy if you don't know what
it's about by the way it's all about
modern physics really it means the
subtitle is from big the Big Bang to
black holes so a lot of large-scale
physics stuff that I think there's also
small-scale in here and it's also
vaguely current with another success
with Sony
theory of everything obviously that with
Eddie Redmayne and that book features
yeah I greatly in this Westaway I
thought you meant has there been like a
theory of everything discovered
No whoa I could mix oh yeah no that's
what other ages I want to read it
actually so thank you for joining us for
this video talking about the
metamorphosis and we hope to see you
next time both of us yeah for a brief
history of time if you did enjoy the
video give it a like and subscribe if
you want to see more put videos by it